Hello and welcome to today's episode of Rawkode
live. I'm your host Rawkode.
Today, we are taking a look at Snyk,
a set of tools to help you develop
fast and stay secure.
Before we begin, there's just a little bit
of housekeeping. If you're not already subscribed to
the YouTube, I would encourage you to do
so now.
Click the subscribe button, tick that bell, and
you will get notifications for all the new
episodes of Rawkode Live at the Rawkode Academy.
We will do our best to provide the
best cloud native resources across the vast cloud
native landscape. It's scary to not walk the
path alone.
Also, if you wanna be able to chat
afterwards or even just now, jump into the
Discord at Rawkode.chat.
We've got over 400 members there talking all
things cloud native, security, Kubernetes,
and even rock music. Very cool.
Alright. Now to catch us on our Snyk
joining us today, I am joined
by Matt Jarvis. Hey, How are you?
Hey, David. I'm good. I'm hot here. I
don't know what it's like in Scotland at
the minute, in the Lake District it's boiling.
You know what? It has been rather hot
the last few days, which I know a
lot of people say is a good problem
to have, but when you don't have AC,
it gets pretty toasty in the house. Right?
Yeah. We're not quite out to Portland kind
of temperatures at the minute. True. Yeah. You
know what it's like though in the North,
like if it gets above about 12 degrees,
it's like, well, this is shorts weather.
Oh, yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I'm unlucky or lucky
to have a window right here and anything
above 12 degrees and it's called Tataph in
Scotland where
all of our local youths like to rip
off their tops and walk around Shirtland which
is Quality.
Wonderful. Yeah.
But yeah, definitely been enjoying the weather.
It's been a nice change for Scotland.
Alright. Well, thanks for joining me today. I'm
excited. Do you wanna for anyone that's not
familiar with you, give us the the TLDR
on you and tell us a little bit
about you. Sure. So so
yeah. I'm
a senior developer advocate at Snyk.
So
I'm sure a lot of folks will be
familiar with what developer advocates do, but we
spend most of our time going around and
talking to people about technology. Right? And waving
our hands a lot. And
so
I've kind of been around the cloud native
space for a pretty long time, I guess,
kind of five, six years. And before that,
I was in OpenStack, you know, around the
OpenStack community. So been doing a lot of
stuff with a lot of clouds for a
lot of time. So
yeah.
Awesome.
Well,
you've already said it now, it's Snyk. The
pronunciation is something that always threw me at
the start and I think that was actually
maybe watching one of your talks where I
fairly clicked. Was like, oh, that makes so
much sense. Why have I been saying Snyk
all this time? So Well, it doesn't help
that there are various people in inside Snyk
who pronounce it differently as well, but
the official pronunciation is Snyk. Yeah. And for
a security company, when that penny drops, you're
like, that's a really name. I'm like, I
get it now. So I like it. Yeah.
It's actually an acronym for so now you
know.
Really? It's kinda where it came from. Yeah.
Okay. That I did not know. So there's
the first knowledge bomb already. What are we?
One one and a half minutes to imagine.
Do you wanna then
if our audience, let's assume they're not familiar
with Snyk and the set of tools that
they offer. Do you wanna give us the
high level overview and then we'll jump into
the hands on component of our show? Yeah.
Of course. So Snyk
are a
security company, but, you know, kind of a
new kind of security company. You know, we're
really focused on developer
first security
and
on building a kind of cloud native platform
for for for security
in
the modern world.
And so we have
a set of tools that kind of all
work together that do everything from
software composition analysis. So where you look at
software where you're using open source modules, open
source packages, and look for vulnerabilities in those
packages
through to container image scanning,
through to
infrastructure code, so things like Terraform and and
Kubernetes YAML.
And then
we also have just released a product called
Snykode,
which does
static application security testing. So looking at homegrown
code that you've written and looking for
vulnerable pathways in in that code.
And
but the all of these tools are really
aimed at
at developers using them. And I think that's
what one of the fundamental things has changed
in terms of
of of security,
you know, over the last few years is,
you know, we've got these these two kind
of things going on. The first is that,
you know, the the the velocity that we're
deploying software at is is dramatically
increased. Right? I mean, when I started out,
you know, you the aim in in in
most
kind of IT environments was to deploy things
as as as little as possible. Right? Just
don't change anything.
And
and now we're really all about speed and
deploying things super fast. So Yeah. You know,
you can't you can no longer have this
kind of thing where you stick security at
the end and say, you know, here's this
final step that we're gonna do before we
deploy something to production because, ideally, you wanna
be deployed to production all the time.
And then I suppose the second big thing
that's driving these changes in security is the
fact that developers are responsible for much more
of the stack than they than they used
to be. You know, if we look at
I mean, you know, you may as well
consider the container and your application the same
thing. Right? Because when do you ever deploy
the application
outside of the container? You know, never.
And quite often, it's the same team building
the container image that might even be creating
the Kubernetes YAML to deploy it into Kubernetes.
And, you know, all that stuff used to
be some other team's, you know, kind of
responsibility.
And so, you know, when we consider those
two things together,
you kinda need to have a look at
security in a different way because, you know,
developers are really the people who need to
be
aware of the implications of of of the
stuff that they're doing in in all of
those spaces. So that's the kind of 10,000
foot view, I guess. And I I think
we'll probably get discuss this a bit more
as we kind of explore how Snyk works
and and,
you know, how it's how it you'll see
what the focus is when you look at
it.
Yeah. Definitely. I think there's some really great
points in there. And, it kinda made me
pause for thought for a minute, I was
thinking back about my career and all that
code that I've shipped to production.
And if you'd asked me if it was
secure, the answer would be I
don't know. I don't think I've ever really
considered that with the code that I write.
I mean, if I if I had I
mean, if I think back to ten years,
and I'm gonna try and correlate this to
what you said about the way that things
have changed lately is that
ten years ago if I was shutting something
to production, I would write it in a
single language, you know, would have been PHP
or Perl or whatever. There's no single framework.
It'd be a monolithic application. I would deploy
it once every three months probably.
And if I was working for a company
that was particularly risk averse, we'd maybe get
an audit
every other year or something like that.
And that was And they do they do
a scan of the yeah. Yeah. Exactly. I
mean, was the same same for me. But
I mean, you know, presumably, was somebody else
creating the virtual machine image that you deployed
it onto. Right? And somebody else was organizing
the network connectivity for it and they probably
somebody else created the storage land that it,
like, sat on.
Yeah. Yeah. Definitely a a very
a lot of segmentation on the different parts
of the life cycle and the deployment and
all of that. Now I'm looking at how
we do software today and micro service environments,
polyglot languages or, you know, multiple languages across
micro service architectures,
deploying daily or even more than daily.
And then just thinking about the security concerns
that we have and how those are essentially
multiplied or exponential, maybe even at the worst
case and that kind of environment is scary.
So
Yeah. And I mean, I I think if
you look at the real world of kind
of of
when people get owned, right, there's a there's
it's almost always in in this era, a
combination of application level vulnerability.
But what really causes this, the massive blast
radius is you've misconfigured the environment.
And that might be, you know, Kubernetes.
That might be, you know, how you've done
Terraform into AWS,
you know, and once.
So, you know, this it's interesting to see
how,
you know an attacker isn't really likely to
get much from from owning one container,
but once you get to, like you know,
you get in there, you can expand the
blast radius because somebody hasn't misconfigured something, they've
exposed some secrets somewhere, you know, then you're
into a whole different game.
Yeah. Definitely. Yeah. I can see that especially,
you know, as our applications are distributed now,
they all have their own APIs
misconfigured any of those, getting authentication wrong in
any of those, and you're just leaving doors
open for nefarious people to jump in sneak
in and then start moving laterally. So yeah.
And now we never wanna write software again
unless
there's a tool chain Yeah. It's all about
notebook now. Don't write anything.
Yeah. Unless we've got tools out there to
help us remove some of these common pain
points and make ourselves worse. I think that's
why I'm really excited for today's lesson. Because
I don't wanna stop writing code. I just
I want a better confidence that my code
is potentially secure. I mean, in fact, I
even think in the last twelve months, like
every major hack I think I've read about
has been supply chain.
And I think that's a growing concern for
everyone now, especially as open source is a
major component of everything that we're doing and
been able to make sure that not only
our code that we write is secure,
but the code of the upstream dependencies that
we have as well.
I mean, I think if you look at
most applications these days,
it's it's extremely rare to not see this
pattern, which is like a tiny amount of,
like, code that you've actually written in the
context of the entire application.
And then, you know, I mean, god, you
know, hundreds of thousands of lines of code
that you've just pulled in from from
NPM or from PyPI or from where I
mean, that's how we write applications now. Right?
I mean, it's it's great because we're not
reinventing the wheel. I mean, you know, who
would go out and write their own
HTTP library or something like that? You know,
you just wouldn't now, would you? You just,
you know, include whatever. Yeah. But,
you know, there is the
it's,
you know, it can be a place where
where you introduce vulnerability. So I think being
aware of that and and having the mechanisms
to to scan that stuff.
I mean, you know, I came from the
Python world where it's a bit simpler, I
think. I I think if you look at
a lot of a lot of of of
ecosystems now, especially things like JavaScript,
there's like a million different packages to do
all sorts of stuff. And then you've got
the typo squatting stuff, right, where people will
push a push a package with a tiny
typo in it to to catch people from
the repository. So it's a bit of a
minefield just in just in that sense.
Yeah. Definitely.
Well, it's rare on this show but I'm
I'm sold. I'm convinced. I now wanna see
all the goodies. So
so why don't I get my screen share
up here?
There we go. We are floating heads. We
have the Snyk website
and we're gonna try and do a few
things today. We're gonna take a JavaScript project.
We are gonna add it to the Snyk
UI. We're gonna do a little bit of
exploration there first and then we're gonna get
hands on with some of the developer tools
as well.
So let's see. I need to log in.
Oh, the beach ball, that's always a good
sign.
Okay.
I hope I used GitHub. Did you ever
get that? When you go to a website
and you're like, I can't remember what I
used. All time.
Okay. So this is the
Snyk UI. I logged in with GitHub. I've
got my organization here. We're gonna add a
project. Now,
I'm not gonna say I I've cheated, but
I've just farted on another project. I think
it would be cool to analyze and and
see all the things that are coming on
here. So
oh, I guess I could have used all
our economic stuff. I'll just hide that.
I fought n a n. Are you familiar
with the the project at all? I
don't think I am actually. It's a workflow
automation tool written in JavaScript and TypeScript
that has a really nice kinda UI
for doing your workflows.
I'm just gonna tick this here
and hit go.
And I'll give that a few seconds and
I'll just jump over to here and show
you this. Really cool tool. I I keep
like I try to automate as much of
this show as possible and this gives you
like this nice drag and drop node collection
thing where you just say like, oh Oh,
that looks shiny. I mean, GitHub fires an
event going to this thing. So I figured
let's let's play with that.
In order Check out.
Because Docker image scans,
Docker image building is particularly slow,
upfront I did do a build of the
container image and push it just so that
we don't need to do that on my
machine and watch that
watch the build. That's that's just not fun.
So I figured I'd save as that.
Okay. So I guess I guess, you know,
looking at this looking at this view, one
of the key things, you know, like I
was saying about this focus on on these
are tools for developers to use, you know,
to make it as easy as possible for
you to to import stuff into
your
into into Snyk and have it scanned. So
it's all really about frictionless.
And if you look at the amount of
integrations there are, you know, you can you
can, like, plug Snyk into,
like, a ton of different source code management
systems,
ton of different CI tools,
and and all sorts of thing all all
sorts of container registries. And, you know, it's
as simple as as you just showed their
way. You just click the button and, you
know, it's there. It's been scanned already. Right?
Yeah.
It is imported already. I can see it
here.
Wow. It's done quite a lot. So it's
done
a code analysis.
It has scanned all of the Docker files
from all the different so Debian one, Red
Hat one, I guess the scratch or custom
one,
and it's found a package dot JSON. So
at least I didn't know this before today,
but NAN appears to be some sort of
mono repository with a whole bunch of packages
and it has scanned all of their JSON
package dot JSON file.
That's pretty nice right off the bat. I
like that.
What I don't like is the big scary
numbers I've now seen.
Let me see. Can you see that? Oh,
I should probably zoom in a little bit
right. There you go.
Is this h, I guess, high severity?
Like a hundred h is high severity. So
if you I mean, perhaps if you click
on one of those package dot jsons, we
can kinda see what what
what's going on there. Yeah. One that's actually
got some some vulnerabilities in it.
So what what the first thing to to
note here is this dependencies tab. Right? So
if you click on the dependencies tab,
so what you're gonna see there is that
that
Snyk's not just analyzed, like, what packages you
included, but it's built the entire dependency tree
and analyzed all of them. And so you
may have things that are I mean, actually,
it looks like at the top level, there
aren't any vulnerabilities
in those in those top level ones. So
presumably, the phones there are all in the
tree. Yeah. Okay.
So and and this is where lots of
vulnerabilities can hide, right, is in these indirect
dependencies that you didn't actually know you're including.
Right? And, I mean, I'm sure you're familiar
particularly with node, where sometimes you can just
get a ridiculous amount of packages all of
a sudden get like get get included there.
But it's built the it's built the whole
tree and looked at the looked at the
vulnerability database for for every package, every version
of every package that's that's been included there.
So I'm I'm curious. Right? Like,
it says we've got high, medium, and low
severity.
Like, is there a a one liner description
for what that actually means to me as
as a developer? Like, can I ignore? Or
would you go back to if you go
if you go back to issues, right, and
we can talk through a bit about what
about what that means. So what
what
so security vulnerabilities typically are are
are there is an industry standard for how
things are scored. Right? The CVSS score. And
the CVSS score is made up of a
bunch of of sort of different elements that
altogether add up to an overall score
that says how severe that thing is. And,
you know, those if I think if you
click on that CVSS,
you know, in that in that vulnerability we're
looking at there, the CVSS thing, which is
that that one there,
will actually take you to the, yeah, to
the c v so you can see all
these different things like the attack vectors, the
complexity required
for the attack, what privileges you need. You
know, this is this is the kind of
stuff that security folks
are into. Right? And so the for for
maybe people who aren't so familiar with how
these things get get rated,
CVSS is the kind of the basis for
it.
But what we do at Snyk is kind
of enrich that as well. So, you know,
from a developer perspective
yeah. That's very true, Russell. Love that shows
is is
has a history of
but if we if we go back to
Snyk, David, and and you can see that
that we also have this this priority
score.
The see that low that that one we
were just looking at there, it's got that
score of four nine seven.
And that's
based on not just the CVSS score, but
it's based on how
how mature is the are the exploits available
for it. So is there code out there
that's real that somebody could use against it?
But most importantly, and this is the kind
of critical thing for for this idea of
developer first security,
is is there a fix? Right? Because when
you look at these lists of vulnerabilities,
and we'll see when we come to container
images, that sometimes you can just get these
hundreds of vulnerabilities. And it's like, I'm a
developer. What do I do about this? None
of these things mean anything to me. Right?
So am I gonna, like, go through all
these things and see whether they are applicable
in my environment? Blah blah blah. But, you
know so you have to prioritize,
and you have to just make a strategic
decision to say which ones you're gonna fix.
And so stuff that has a fix
and it's severe and it's got exploit, that's
clearly a no brainer. Right? Just fix it.
Because if it just means upgrading that package,
then, obviously, you don't really need to dig
into what the actual vulnerability is. Just fix
it. Because, you know, at some point, you're
gonna have to make these trade offs between
how much effort is it to understand all
these things versus,
you know, the the the effort to fix
it. And so this prioritization
is really important for
us in terms of the how actionable things
are from a developer perspective. Right? Because me
as the developer,
I just wanna fix things and move on.
Right? Because this is the security stuff is
just, you know, is just taking up resource
in my team, which could be better spent
developing new features, shipping new software. Exactly. I've
got bugs to introduce to my software. I
don't have time to be fixing those issues.
You've got new vulnerabilities to introduce.
So that's it. So yeah. So so that
that's kind of I think the question was
I slightly went
off around the piece there, but the question
was about about
sort of scoring of these things. So it's
a combination of the CVSS score, and in
the Snyk world, we kind of enrich that
by saying,
you know, if there's a fix available, we're
gonna highlight that because it's much it it's
the kind of thing that you ought to
be dealing with first.
Yeah.
So I've been kind of peeking at the
UI as as well as you've been explaining
that to me. There's just a lot of
information here as well to really understand each
of these which I think is great. The
fact that it tells me how it was
introduced,
think is really nice. This one just tell
me even where it's fixed.
And then I like these toggles over here
as well.
Not fixable,
which is probably not the best way for
me to
like I guess with those I'm just hoping
that they're still in the proof of concept
stage and then the ones that are fixable
are here. So nice
presentation
of just all of the things that I
need to be concerned about without attracting too
much of my time, which I I like.
So
let's let's see what else we had on
this.
Is it just back? There we go.
And it does that for all of my
package JSON.
Yeah. So I was gonna find another one
where we can do look at a
where there's some fixable ones that you could
do a fixed PR against
Because that's the other thing in that in
that view that you can do is automatically
open a PR against in GitHub against that
repository.
The they'll upgrade that package to the to
the appropriate
to the appropriate version.
Oh, we got a fixable one.
Yeah. So if you click on that, see
that big green button that says fix that
vulnerability?
Okay. So what have we got here? We've
got
seven eleven. That seems like quite a high
score. Yeah. So then that's pretty high.
But but see that why that one is
probably higher than that one we looked at
before is because it's fixable.
So having a fix available is gonna be
it's gonna push that to the top of
the pile so that your developers can go,
hey. There's a fix there. All I need
to do is upgrade that package to I
think we're showing there
if we upgraded it to
Seven dot zero dot zero. Seven dot 0
dot zero.
Okay. And that's what I I suspect, actually,
when we that fixed PR because it's a
because it's a indirect
dependency,
I think it'll upgrade a few packages there
in order to make sure they're all they've
all they're all the right versions. But if
you press the fixed vulnerability,
hopefully,
it should open a a PR in
GitHub.
So
Okay. Right. So that's fine. So we can
open the fixed PR there.
And what it should do is is is
open that in GitHub. So we can see
it's open a nice
informative PR there
that's that's showing you exactly what why you
needed to upgrade it. And I think if
we go in files changed, it should show
that it's just gonna have the package dependency
to the version.
Alright. Let's see.
There we go. Yeah. So there we go.
And you you can have that turned on.
So quite a lot of people have those
turned on automatically
so that they're they're they're it'll automatically open
fixed PRs for for things that can be
that can have a
package upgrade.
Well, that was a
quite a pleasant experience.
We found a high high vulnerability high risk
vulnerability and then Snyk has been very kind
as to give me the PR, upgrade the
dependency
and it's now merged.
That's awesome. Let's
jump back here. So I guess that's going
to I'm assuming Snyk knows
that something has happened here and
does the redo of the analysis is every
time there's a push to my repository?
Yeah. So
did you just merge that? Yeah. So Could
I do? This when you've turned on the
GitHub integration, there is automatically a
it's gonna it's
gonna rescan on merge anyway
because you had the
on the GitHub repo when you imported, it
adds the Snyk tests.
So when that merge has gone through, it's
retested it.
Yeah. Cool.
Let's go back to there is a button
here that I was curious about.
Fix vulnerabilities. Does this try and fix everything?
Or is it just gonna take me to
Alright.
Okay.
Yeah. It should get it should yeah. So
that's on the because that was against the
Dockerfile project, wasn't it? So when you imported
that project, it also looked at the Dockerfiles.
And I think if you went back a
screen, you'd see the little Docker icon there
and where that was saying fix the Yeah.
So this is against the against the docker.
Actually, that against the image in in Docker
Hub, or is that against the Docker file?
Wants to upgrade the base image based on
what I've seen on the last page.
Yeah.
It wants to go from fourteen seventeen to
fourteen seventeen.
Yeah.
So and again, the same the same sort
of thing applies for for Docker images that
we can do these automated fixed PRs against
the Docker file.
I think with Docker images are are a
bit more of a of a complex one
because a lot of Docker images
have a lot of vulnerabilities in them. Right?
And especially
the generic
the generic language
images. You know? I mean, you can see
that node fourteen's got 600 plus vulnerabilities in
it. And there's a reason for that. Right?
It's because
those generic language
runtime
images
are solving for the generic
case, aren't they? That's gotta work with every
node app. So it's gonna have all the
bells and whistles in it.
It's gonna, you know, it's gonna be big.
You know, I I think there's a there's
clearly
well, I mean, I've done whole conference talks
about how you reduce vulnerability counts in in
in Docker images, you know, but, obviously, using
slim,
you know,
slim versions in production is gonna reduce your
vulnerability count. It's probably not a good idea
to be deploying things in production
that use those generic language run times because,
you know, they're just solving for the big
use case. They're great for trying things out
because you know they're gonna work every time,
but you probably don't wanna deploy that in
production. I mean, I think if you click
the show more upgrade types there
on the left there, there should probably be
some yeah. There you go. So the node
slim images,
you know, have much less vulnerabilities in them.
Right.
Okay. And I I guess that's just because
they have
less less packages
and the Yeah. Yeah. I mean, less less
packages, clearly. And I mean, you know, so
but there's, you know, the workflow that that
people
I mean, if you probably, for example, you
you couldn't use that to build your application,
that that slim image because it's not gonna
have your build tools in there. Yeah. But,
you know, the so this is where this
idea of of multistage builds comes into play.
Right? So if I'm in my in my
build system, I probably do wanna be using
maybe I do wanna use that node 14.15
base image to build my software, but then
I wanna take that software
out of that
and put it into a slim image for
deployment in a multistage build.
So,
yeah, probably too much too much to go
into in in this session, but,
you know, there are lots of folks who
who talk very eloquently about
the best practices for
for for managing
container images in production. Right? But, yeah, generic
language run times are not usually a very
good choice for
from security perspective.
It's one of those things that I think
I know in the back of my head
and I just have never really
never really given enough attention to think, yeah,
I probably should try and either build my
own. It's just so easy to use these
generic ones, isn't it? Because things just I
mean, I
I think that's always the path of least
resistance is always a bit of the issue,
isn't it? You know? And I mean, I
I guess the flip side to that is
the same with
with
tools that can help us. We don't want
things that are gonna put loads of barriers
in our way. So that's what we try
to do with Snyk is to say, well,
look, here's the solution, you know, an easy
solution that's not that doesn't loads of friction
for you. So
yeah.
Alright. Let's see what else we've got on
this UI then.
I'll go back to the home page.
This is all my vulnerabilities
and project. So I think we probably had
some more interesting things to look at in
that in that particular project. Right?
Yeah. We still got the code analysis that
we haven't clicked on yet. I've got a
good grasp of what the package JSON scanning
does. That makes a lot of sense to
me. We looked at the Dockerfile, I got
that that just
nice convenience things. Also the Debian image, lots
of vulnerabilities there, so basically coincides with what
you're saying, don't do that. Like here's the
nice custom bespoke one and you can see
that. Look at that. Six
seven. Sorry. Seven vulnerabilities.
Much better than the hundred I mean, it's
important to I think it's important for to
to to kinda get your head around that
in in container images, you're almost never gonna
have zero vulnerabilities.
I mean, it's just not that's not that
shouldn't really be your goal
to have zero because unless you've unless you've,
like, built a scratch image and all you
put in it is, like, a compiled c
binary or a go binary,
It's just not realistic.
So you kind of have to you have
to set
set,
I guess, a strategy. Right? And, I mean,
you know, I I kinda say, well, perhaps
your strategy is, like,
no no high vulnerabilities in production that have
an exploit
and nothing that has a fix. Yeah. That
might be a good strategy. That'll probably get
you down to, you know, very small numbers
of vulnerabilities. But, yeah, aiming for zero is
probably not realistic.
Yeah. And it feels to me like I
I don't know if it's quite half the
battle, but I'm gonna say half the battle
is just being aware of which vulnerabilities actually
exist in my prod environment. Because I'm assuming,
if I know the seven or 20 vulnerabilities
I've got, I could maybe put things in
place to make sure they're not exploitable
in my environment even if there's not a
ready fix available. It could just be blocking
firewall ports or certain endpoints on your app
or whatever.
Yeah. Exactly. I mean, you know, I
is always a bit about trade offs really,
isn't it? You know, it's about trade off
between effort versus risk.
And so, you know, you might decide that
let's say, for example,
you know, we only perhaps we only care
about vulnerabilities that are exploitable
over the network.
And when we look at the CLI scanning,
we can talk a bit about how you
can actually, like,
sort of filter results,
you know, based on those CVSS things just
to get say, only give me high things
that are exploitable over the network. But you
because you might decide that actually
things that require a local shell
I'm just not exploited. The risk of them
being exploited in my environment is minimal because
I use distro list for everything, which doesn't
have any shells or,
you know, whatever. But, you know,
there there's always there's always sort of trade
offs of of
decision making about how you decide whether something's
exploitable in your environment or not.
Awesome.
Thank you for that. So do you wanna
jump into what we look at code analysis?
Yeah. So code analysis is a is is
very cool. This is pretty new.
This is about vulnerabilities
in your own code. And I think if
we when we look at if we have
a look at Versus Code,
you know, it probably shows, you know, some
of the things that are really cool about
about Snykode.
So
this this kind of analysis used to be
super slow.
And, you know, years ago, you used to
have, like, you'd run these things overnight, you
know, and they they turned
turned up millions of
of false positives and, you know, they were
really just there. Like you said earlier, you
know, oh, we do this once a quarter
for audit and someone writes a report and
then, you know, everybody ignores it or whatever.
But
so Snykode actually uses machine learning. So it's
got it's it's fast enough to to do
in real time in your IDE.
But what's really focused on is code errors.
So in your own code, not code that
you've brought in through a package or whatever.
This is stuff you've written yourself.
And
so I what I really like is it
shows you the flow of what's gonna happen.
I don't know whether it does it in
the UI actually, but in the in the
so what happens if you click full details?
I have to admit, I've not looked at
this much inside the the web UI. Well,
I'm just loving the description of these here.
Like, this one is telling me that we
can have exception flows. I'm assuming that's because
we got, you know, random access or variable
access to maps,
which is obviously scary.
This one I'm assume is telling me that
I've got unsanitized input from HTTP,
which I'm assuming the fail path comes from
and we're throwing that straight into a function.
And you know what? These are like, oh,
you know, they work at the time. It
shows you it
shows you actually how oh, look. No. There
you go. So it'll show you in the
code how that's got in there. So if
you click through all those steps,
it'll show you, you know, it's gone through
and gone. Here's where this got it came
in. Here's where it's flowing through. It's flowing
through here. It's flowing through here. And then
you use it like this.
That is ridiculous. It's super cool.
Oh, that is awesome.
Yeah. And, I mean, it'll do that in
the in the
in in
in the IDE, like, what you know, in
as a live scan
and show you exactly the code path by
which that that so presumably, we're talking about
that file path that
file path variable there. Right?
Yeah. It's nice how you can see how
it kinda it gets composed together. You can
see here we're accessing the params
on the HTTP request to get a name.
're then calling a function, passing it in,
and then it leaks through until eventually we
pass it into the send file.
Yeah. It's neat, isn't it? And I think
if you click on the fix analysis
there, it should show you examples of how
yeah. So there you go. So it's behind
the scenes, it's also got this massive
learning database of of open source code. Right?
So it actually
show you how other projects have
fixed the same problem.
So you've got three, I think, example fixes
there from different open source projects.
So it's showing you examples of how,
you know, not just, you know, how how
you
could fix it, but how others have fixed
the same the same things. So I'll give
you examples from the real world.
Nice. It's neat. Right?
Yeah. I didn't expect to get like just
that one screen with the way the code
flows through. That was
that was neat. I like that a lot.
And you're saying that works in my Versus
Code as well. Do want should we pop
it open?
Yeah. If you've got the Snyk plugin
installed in your Versus Code,
it should it should do it. Do you
have a little Snyk icon somewhere?
Yep. There we go. Yeah. You have. Right?
So
and and I assume you I think you
need to auth via the CLI, but if
you've had the CLI working, it should already
be authed?
No. I haven't actually installed the CLI. There's
something I'll use. Oh, I think it's working
there anyway. Right? I'm I'm
that's a bit small for my old eyes
to see in this window, but
It's the right I think yeah. So this
is all coming from Snykode. Yeah. So so
you can see these.
And I think if you write
yeah. So that's showing you the and if
you right click, it should get
you should get the
the extra window that gives you yeah. There
you go.
So you you should have the same thing
there where it's saying showing the flows.
Let's see if can get the same one
so it matches up.
There we go. There's the same one. Okay.
Yeah.
Nice.
Yeah. So you get all that same stuff
in your IDE, and that that will actually,
you know it's it's fast enough that you
can be getting that stuff while you
while you're
coding.
I like that it's actually in my IDE.
I'm actually getting a red squiggle from the
vulnerability scanner. You know, it's like no. It's
not an error, but it's definitely a high
vulnerability thing that I probably wanna be aware
of and then the description of the issue
here.
So that kind of integration is good because
then it's front and center with me all
the time when I'm writing my code. Well,
I mean, that yeah. And that's again, that's
part of this developer first thing is, like,
you know because, really,
I mean, I don't know whether you've you've
you've read
things like I I assume that the the
cloud native security white paper, but that the
that CNCF six security did last year and
Liz Rice's book on on cloud native security
and things. You know, it's really about sort
of
integrating security all the way through
our
SDLC.
Right? Because, you know, we're in
CICD pipeline kind of mode and and code
continuously flowing. So what we need to do
really is to integrate in all points in
that in that process. And the first point
is clearly developer eyeballs. Right? This is the
place where it's cheapest to fix.
And, you know, so providing tools that give
developers easy insights into issues before they even
get into into
source code management
is clearly gonna be your best your your
best point to start at.
So these kind of integrations are really,
you know, sort of key for us is
make it super easy to for developers to
get that information right in the ID, right
in the CLI,
you know, and and and so you can
fix things
super easily, super quickly.
Nice. I like that. Very, cool.
Okay. So
I don't think we're gonna be able to
fix 50 issues,
But that number doesn't seem as scary to
me as some of those Docker container image
ones, so that's at least a positive.
Lots of details.
Very cool. Alright.
Let's jump back over. Where were we? Projects.
Is there anything else on the UI side
of things that we should take a look
at?
So there's obviously a lot of functions. I
mean, it's probably less interesting to this organization,
but, you know, there's a lot of that
stuff about
how you would do things in a bigger
organization. So being able to ignore things, being
able to report on things.
But I think we've we've sort of
covered the the the developer,
you know, kind of focused bits in the
in the UI,
I think.
Mhmm. What about importing Docker images from
Docker Hub?
Okay. So is that do I add a
new thing?
Yep. No. Yeah. Oh, you so you haven't
got
yeah. So you'll need to
add connect with with Docker Hub. If we
go down a little bit, there we go.
I'll maybe move that over here.
Yeah. Maybe take that off the screen temporarily.
Where'd it go?
One,
two.
There we go. Okay. Let me grab my
token then from the Docker Hub.
Talking new
Snyk.
And there we go.
You hate it anyway. I'll see if
and see if
there we go. So now if you wanna
scan your images
on an ongoing basis that you've got in
Docker Hub, It's as simple as it was
importing from the
from from
GitHub.
And this works with a whole bunch of
different registries. Right?
ECR,
Quave,
who else?
Google,
blah blah blah. Pretty much everybody.
Yeah. There was quite a lot of
options there, wasn't there?
And it seems to work with pretty much
all the major source code repositories.
Yeah. Some of them Some of them like
Yes.
We're working on on on on more of
them.
Some of them, you know, are are a
sort of paid upgrade because it tends to
be more enterprise customers who are using those
ones.
But
Yeah. All the major CIs,
all the editors. Wow. That's a lot of
integration.
But it it seems to me it doesn't
really matter what stack your organization is using.
It's gonna be covered. Yeah. And, I mean,
in in a lot of cases, you know,
if it's not there and, I mean, you'd
have to be pretty far off the beaten
track for this not to be like a
first class integration.
But a lot of times, you can integrate
just with the CLI anyway. Right? Especially if
you're in a if you're doing CI stuff,
for example, you know, you can write CI
string CLI strings that are gonna be able
to glue together almost anything. So,
yeah, it's integrations are kinda key part of
of
making it super easy for folks to use.
I'm curious about this Kubernetes one here. Does
that scan, like, my deployments for maybe anti
patterns over exposing too many ports, like or
if I just made that up? To be
a container.
No, because
so at the minute, we're not doing
we're not doing deployed environment scanning for configuration
in Kubernetes.
It's definitely something we're we're looking at. If
you if you just
scroll up slightly,
one thing that is coming soon is is
and in some ways, we'd probably do the
a similar thing with Kubernetes, but is we're
we've got this this thing to scan deployed
AWS environments.
So Oh, yeah. You know, rather as well
as just being able to look at Terraform
before you've actually spun something up, we can
actually, like, query
your configured AWS environment and say, well, there's
x, you know, security issues there. And that'd
be super cool to do with Kubernetes as
well. Right? It's to be able to look
and say, you know, let's look at the
deployed environment and see whether there are
issues.
In terms of this
scanning
for Kubernetes that that is in there in
the UI that you're seeing, that is
image scanning.
So deployed
deployed containers and
when you so new containers and containers that
are already running in your Kubernetes cluster.
So
you get a similar thing, you know, if
I enable the the Kubernetes integration. I get,
like
I can see all the images that are
running in my cluster, and I can choose
to scan them in the same way that
I can from Docker Hub.
Okay. Yeah. That that definitely makes a lot
of sense then. I like that as well.
Oh, there's my image. So this is now
added Yes, Kyle. My Docker Hub image that
I built just before we went live.
Let's see what we've got here. Okay.
So this is
so what does the I'm curious then. What
does it mean when it scans a container
image? Like, is it looking at the Docker
file and saying,
this image has this, looking at the commands
or is it actually pulling the image and
inspecting what's inside of it? It's pulling the
image and looking at what's inside it. And
so it'll be identifying
so there are two there are two things
going on here that you can link the
Dockerfile as well and get so if you
have the Dockerfile in a GitHub repository, for
example,
you can link the two things together,
which gives you will give you deeper insights
into how you might fix things. So that
base image recommendation stuff that we looked at
from the Dockerfile,
that's difficult to do just by looking at
the image. But if you combine those two
things, you'll get both. So you can say
this image in Docker Hub and this Docker
file in GitHub are the same thing, and
it'll give you the base image recommendations.
But what you could see here that's kinda
neat is it'll show you what the in
which layers
the
those particular vulnerabilities have been introduced in. So
we can see that APK tools one is
coming I'm assuming this is now based image,
and
that's being introduced
sort of by the base image.
But if we look at the busy box
one, it looks like that's been that's been
added into the image by
by another layer in the Dockerfile.
Yeah. Correct.
Yeah. There's a whole bunch of stuff happening.
It's detected that from the from the built
image. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
But it does tell me there's a fix
if I upgrade my BusyBox SSL client. So
Yeah. It's handy.
So and you could see on there, you
can filter on the left by image layers
there. So you've got six that are in
the user instructions and Oh, yeah. And one
that's in the base image.
So I'm assuming again,
my
eyes are slightly struggling there, but I'm assuming
probably that rebuilding that.
If that's fixed, where is it installing
open SSL, limit SSL?
So it's doing an APK update
at
as I build dependencies Python build. But yeah.
So it looks like it's adding a whole
bunch of It might actually be that. It
might actually be yeah. If you rebuilt that
image, it might actually fix those.
Oh, I I think these are probably penned
somehow just because I know
Oh, maybe. Yeah. I built this recently, like
only an hour ago. No. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. I'm not sure.
In fact, this is the version
that we oh, no. That's version I and
there's a version k. Yeah. There's maybe something
here. It's not quite shipped to Alpine yet.
Yeah.
But that that's an interesting point about about
Docker images in general. And one of the
reasons for
monitoring them on an ongoing basis as well
as, like, scanning them when you're when you're
making them. Right? So when I if I
build a Docker image locally before I push
it to the registry,
I'm gonna scan it and see whether it's
vulnerable. I might make some changes, scan it
again,
you know, and I finally got my my
image where I want it, and I push
it to my my registry.
But, you know, what happens in, like, three
months' time? I mean, I know I've got
things in my own Docker Hub that I
have to say I haven't rebuilt for years.
And, you know, so that that scans ongoing
over time. And, I mean, you've imported this
one into into Snyk, and that'll be scanned
every twenty four hours.
So it's kind of important to make sure
that you scan these things on an ongoing
basis because
new vulnerabilities happen all the time. Right? And,
you know,
I I think we had to we we
surveyed
some we did a big survey last year,
I think, and, you know, it was like
one of the questions was, how do you
find out about
vulnerabilities for container images you've already got in
production? I think it was something like 25%
of people said they didn't know. It's like,
okay.
Yeah. I think I I fall You might
wanna be worried about
a minute to that camp where
yeah.
I I just guess I I'm I'm fortunate
that I don't run a lot of stuff
in production that's not being used by thousands
of customers or anything like that, know. I
I'm a developer advocate like you. Like, we
spend half our time just hacking on stuff
and throwing out. Exactly. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So
I know I noticed we had a quick
question in the chat there saying, can you
scan like this on the free tier?
Yeah. Everything I think everything that that we've
looked at so far is
is all available in the free tier.
That's very cool.
I
can imagine that would be quite easy.
Like, I don't know. I feel like if
I did have stuff in production and I
I had all of this stuff, I would
just be on a mission to get those
numbers as low as possible all the time.
I I think I'd end up making a
game of it and just be like, hey.
How many of these are going think it's
interesting when you do start to we see
we actually see that quite a lot, right,
is that that
a lot of the adoption of tools like
Snyk is is you know, rather than being
it used to the way security used to
work was, like, you know, you'd have some
tool would be bought by the chief security
officer and just given, you know, you will
use this.
And what what we actually find is that
that developers
are start are choosing
to use this quite often than one small
team will start
because they want to make sure that their
stuff is secure. They know that that, you
know, they're in control of a lot more
stuff now than they used to be. And
they we do see that it kinda gets
a bit gamified, know, that people are like,
oh, I wanna get those numbers down, you
know.
Yeah. You could have, like, company hackathons where
you owe me up once a month for
something and just order some pizza, some beers,
and just, like, like, let's go squash some
of these vulnerabilities.
And that would be a whole lot of
Yeah. I mean, I I I think I
was talking to
to some of the folks in Cloud Native
Nordics, and they were saying that
that,
you know, teams
get quite into the idea of of having
the lowest or whatever. Because,
you know, until you have this information, you
just don't know, do you? You're like, I
know. Yeah. I think just to
bring in that visibility front and center and
the IDE and the pool request,
having the UI like this so anyone can
go check it out. You know, once you
have those numbers, you can then start to
build work on remediation and track that number
coming down like, you know, the worst thing
I could do is be obvious and the
number continues to rise and rise and rise.
And
eventually, when I was And that's that's all
in the in the UI as well. It
might not be in the you know, some
of that's more a kinda enterprise y features,
the reporting and things. But, you know, it'll
show you that number of vulnerabilities over time
across all your projects for a particular project.
You know, that that sort of that information's
all all there for you as well.
I think one of the one of the
interesting things as well was about
GitHub.
If you did you can you pull up
pull up the that repository that we just
imported, the get the the
pull request that you merged, David.
Because you should see the what happens in
GitHub as well, the the automatic scan.
Yep. Rawkode
and it's in.
So if you look to that PR,
you should see the Snyk scan were were
actually ran when you when the the PR
was
are we gonna see it there?
If you scroll down, it should say that
it's
I don't know. Perhaps it's not there. Then
maybe we need to enable something?
Yeah.
Possibly.
But, you know, you'll get the check-in in
GitHub, you know, when every time you push
a push a a PR,
you should you you can have a a
Snyk scan at that point. So, you know,
it won't it won't be
you can't merge it until that scan's passed
and all that kind of good stuff, basically.
Nice.
So there's there's kinda something else I think
is really cool about this. It's like so
far we've been looking at this any end
project. We've looked at it from a code
point of view to get out, which is
JavaScript and TypeScript and the image.
But but I actually added
other non JavaScript stuff to this. So it's
like I don't need to write in JavaScript,
Node and TypeScript to get the benefits of
the Snyk tool. Like this is my a
Go project that I work on and it's
also got
scans and vulnerabilities.
So what what's the language support like for
Snyk?
Pretty wide and getting wide all the time.
So
on some some of the
go Snyk code is obviously less
wide at the minute.
But
in in Snyk
opens what we call the open source, which
is the the package scanning stuff,
Python,
.net,
go
what else? Let me look it up.
A whole bunch of libraries that of languages
that
that I never use. But
Let me pull up the website. I think
there's a list there too.
Yeah.
.Net,
Java,
JavaScript,
Go,
PHP,
Node.
Yeah. A lot.
Nice.
Where is it? I'm sure I've seen that
earlier.
Yeah. There's like a there's a bar somewhere
of Yeah. Oh, there we go. Java, JavaScript,
Takespeare, Python. Okay. That was more than that.
I've seen it earlier. I can't remember where
I saw it. Yeah. The others if you
go
That's integrations.
Right?
I think it's there across the bottom, isn't
it? Yeah. The these ones in gray. Yeah.
Yeah. JavaScript.netJava.
What are you?
Is that one of you just Elixir, isn't
it?
Elixir is the one in the Oh Ruby.
Drop. Yep. We've Ruby, jQuery, npm, PHP.
Oh, that's the postgres elephant. Right? No.
I can't remember. There we go. Go for
Ruby, Python. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. Lots of stuff
there. So Yeah. What
languages you're working with, what tools you're working
with. Snyk just seems to be And we're
and we're we're launching more and more all
the time.
Yeah. Very cool.
And a very generous feature. Thing that that
that will be added to that is so
we just acquired a company called FOS ID,
who
look for snippets
of open source code within
you know, for, like,
say someone's been copy pasting open source code
into your
proprietary product. I would never have. So at
some point, that will start a pit surfacing
in Snyk as well is snippet stuff.
So identifying
snippets which may have come from other other
projects.
Very handy.
A comment on a chat suggested that maybe
Scala,
the three bars. And I'm glad you said
that, Russell, because I thought that too.
And it just wasn't brave enough to go
for the guess.
And we got a comment from b mad
who says, I'll be using this service to
shame other team members and appear smarter than
I really am. Go for it, man. That's
that's an awesome use case.
I would encourage everybody to
Cool.
Is there anything else that we should cover?
If I if I've forgotten anything?
We could take a look at the CLI
scanning quickly. We haven't had a look at
the CLI yet, have we? No. Let's do
that.
So I mean, I actually end up using
the CLI
more miles more than than I use the
the UI.
Alright. Let's see. Install. Can I just brew
install this? Or is there a binary?
Yeah.
If you've got an MPM, you can just
do MPM install minus g.
I'll just copy this link here. I think
we should be good.
Oh, no. I'm I'm in there. Okay.
Snyk.
Tap.
Although, not sure what would have been faster.
NPM installed s g or brew and snow.
Both are particularly slow for me all the
time.
Just pick my poison I normally do it
with NPM,
but
So I have no idea. I I'm hoping
brew is gonna work now. It it's in
our docks. It must someone must have tested
it.
Yeah. I'm sure it'll be good.
Yeah. I think if it gets this far,
it means it's yeah. There we go.
Okay. So
let's see what happens here.
Come on homebrew.
And I'll just drag my window up so
people can actually see the line that I'm
typing.
There.
It says a %, but it's still making
me wait. That's rude.
There we go.
Does that mean I've got a sneak command?
Yeah. So you're
that all so the first thing you need
to do is auth.
So you need your
token thingy from
from your user.
So Okay.
Let me
move my window out the way.
I've already flashed more tokens on the show
than I would like. So Yeah. So
go into your account settings
and API token.
I don't see it. Is it service accounts?
Yeah. No. In in so if you go
up to your where your account section at
the top right of the screen Yeah. Account
settings
Yes. And it should be in the first
thing under general. It should be API token.
Oh, I must be missing it. It might
be really silly.
Hold on. I'll bring it back onto the
screen.
So,
yeah, it won't it won't appear
anyway unless you click it. So
yeah. So no. No. Not not those settings.
Your personal settings. So go to right top
right hand corner there, account settings. That's it.
There we Alright.
Don't click it.
Alright. I'll move it back over here. Don't
click on screen.
I'll bring that back.
I've got my terminal here.
Yeah. Terminal off screen as well. And then
you do sneak off.
The author then paste my
token.
Oh, actually, you don't need the the API
token. You know, you can just do it
through the browser. So if you ran Snyk
auth, it should have opened the browser, yeah,
and given you a
given you a thing saying,
do you want to authenticate the CLI?
Did you get that? Oh, I posted a
token. So I believe that I'm now Alright.
Although I've just realized
that my auto complete
I move off screen again for one second.
I'm gonna run a different Snyk command. Yeah.
So just just click just click that authenticate
button there, David, and that'll do it. That'll
do it for you. Oh, no. But I
You need the you don't need the API
token anymore.
Yeah. I already pasted the API token, so
if I push, like, I was worried that
when I do a sneak, they all complete
would commence. I've just done a quick sneak
dash dash help to hide that. Oh, okay.
Even though I can just regen the token
right after the stream, but I'll try and
avoid displaying it to the world. So
okay. We're there and that that's the that's
the folder. That's the git checkout of the
the thing we've been looking at Yeah. Today,
isn't it? So if you just run Snyk
test from there,
it should
it'll do the open source the packages test,
I hope.
Alright. Because you've got multiple so what it's
saying there is because it found multiple package
dot JSONs because that's a meta repository.
So what we wanna do is actually to
use minus minus all projects.
Yeah. What's up in there? I feel to
it.
And the run dash d.
Let's see what the debug says.
No, Russell.
No token flashing today.
Right. Okay. So you've got because it's node,
you've gotta do NPM install first
in that in that directory.
I was I'm trying to work out if
I could do a find package dot JSON
run command. Yeah. So you can you can
just I mean, to to save you building
that pack building that that
thing, we can just test that single one
there.
I think if you do minus minus file,
is it? To to specify the
Why don't we do the more interesting? I
think the core had a whole bunch of
stuff in it. So we're we can
let's run our NPM install here. Hopefully, that
doesn't take too long, and then I'll try
this sneak test on this directory.
Because this time, the
browser one.
Yeah.
I'm sure core was the one that had
a whole bunch of stuff in it.
I suspect Yeah. See one of them one
of them was interesting,
wasn't it? It didn't have any vulnerabilities.
Yeah. Of course, of course,
I picked that one.
Yeah. It's the packages. It's the CLI one
that was that had some stuff in it.
Alright.
Alright. Cancel. Cancel. Cancel.
A good thing that note installs are super
fast. Right?
Sarcasm.
Let's
see.
I I guess you get to tell me
a story for the next twenty minutes. What
have you got?
I'm sure it would take yeah. Look at
that. Oh, there we go. It is going.
Just had to get started first. And I
hadn't had a coffee yet.
Yeah. That's all.
Get up to speed.
So you said that you So we should
look at we should also look at so
why don't we look at some Kubernetes YAML
while
while that's have you got you got an
you got something with some Kubernetes YAML in
it so we can take a look at
scanning that?
I've got YAML. I've always got YAML.
Let's see.
Let's see if I've got my
That's not interesting. Let's go to the Rawkode
one.
I have
opt Kubernetes.
I've got a deployment. I've got a postgres
stateful set and I've got a service. Is
that enough?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
So
Does that mean I can run Snyk test
here?
So you want Snyk I
c test?
Like that?
Yep. Should be. Yep.
Let me just
Yeah. There we go. That should so what
that's gonna do
Oh, nice.
Yeah. There we go. Right? So
so if we scroll up a bit and
this obviously works the same in the in
the UI.
So that's gonna show you
security issues within that Kubernetes YAML. So what
have we got? Oh, so
you haven't got allow privilege escalation set to
false
in a security context
setting.
You aren't setting runners on route
and
not dropping all the default capabilities,
etcetera.
So we'll we'll
See, that's fun when I was looking at
someone else's code, but now it's analyzing my
YAML and feeling attacked.
Yeah. I should be. I should do better
there. But now I know. Now I've got
a sneak IAC test and I can actually
fix these things.
Yeah. I mean, again, a lot of this
visibility, isn't it? You know, mean, there there's
there's clearly
you know, there might be scenarios where well,
I mean,
allow privilege escalation set to true is hard
one to justify, but, you know,
there are clearly scenarios
where you might want to do all these
other things.
Well, yeah. The these are throwaway clusters and
deployments for clustered. So Yeah. That's actually a
good scenario.
Yeah.
But I love that. Can do that stuff.
Very cool.
So the IAC
tooling, obviously, will scan Kubernetes, YAML, scan Helm
charts,
scan Terraform as well. Really lots and lots
of rule sets about Terraform. So for AWS,
for Google,
for Azure,
and, you know, we'll detect security issues
in in all of those things. And, this
is, you know, this is kind of important
for people to to think about, isn't it?
Because it's not just about your container image.
It's like how are you deploying it,
especially in
in Kubernetes.
And you you almost need to consider the
the deployment
of the application as part of the application,
don't you? Because, you know, it it's all
part of the same thing.
So your application can be as secure as
you like, but if you're spawning that container
as root with, like, you know, no AppArmor
or or whatever, then
you you kind of you you're undoing all
the all the good work that you may
have done in in developing this app to
start with. Right. Well, let's let's be honest.
Right? AppArmor and SE Linux, nobody actually knows
how they work. Right? I mean It is
black magic. Although I've been doing this talk
with with my friend Camille Potrich about about
kernel
privilege escalation
in in Kubernetes. Like, what happens in in
on bare metal and what happens in in
in Kubernetes.
And so he's been explaining to me in
a bit more depth what some of these
things in the kernel actually do.
And,
you know, with privilege with kernel hacks, you
know, fair enough, they're pretty rare.
But
the AppArmor and SELinux
are about the only things that really give
you any protection
in
in scenarios like that where you've got really
serious
kernel bugs that can be exploited
from a local shell.
Yeah. I I must say I'm I'm guilty
of SC and four zero and turning off
SC limits, but maybe I need to I
need to change their hours.
I mean, to be honest, I've been quite
far away from bare metal for a long
time. I mean, I used to run a
public cloud platform, an open set public cloud
platform. So I was a lot more
you know, that was the kind of stuff
that kept me up at night. It was,
you know, virtual machine escaping.
And, thankfully, again, incredibly rare in the real
world, but so we were always we had
automated
checks for things like,
in our case, AppArmor because we were in
a Bunty shop. But, yeah, I'm I'm far
away from the metal now, David. So unlike
yourself.
I've got nothing but metal these days. It's
a whole lot of fun, I've gotta say.
We got a question. I'm not sure if
I fully understand this. I'm gonna throw it
to you and see what happens. But Russell
is asking if the IAC could perhaps scan
like Azure API gateways.
Is that No. That's that's kind of outside
of the scope of what of what Snyk
does. I'm assuming,
Russell, what you're talking about is, like,
I forget the terminology for this, but but
scanning
for for for
configuration on API gateways and things like that
in in running in the running scenario. Yeah?
Let us know, Russell, and we'll we'll circle
back to that. Yeah. So let's let's let's
take a bet then. Do you think the
note the note install is finished?
Yes.
There you go. Okay.
So
if we were doing a sneak test on
our CLI Yeah. Let's see what happens. I
got another comment, nothing but mail these days.
Okay? I think it's still gonna oh, no.
There we go.
Okay. So we can see that all those
same vulnerabilities
have been picked up by the by the
CLI there Yep. Which is cool.
If you how are they fix is that
the one that had a fixable one in
it?
I I don't know. I'm I'm too busy
trying to work out what Snyk Wizard is,
but I think Snyk Wizard and you'll you'll
see what's what
this will depend on whether there is a
fixable any of those were the fixable ones.
And is it gonna So this is basically
gonna guide you to fixing yeah. It's gonna
guide you to fixing it locally
in the same way that, you know, we
sort of do fix PRs.
This will we'll do it locally for you.
I think it's doing some number crunching at
the moment.
Something else that kinda caught my eye that
maybe you can shed some light on is
telling me if I create a dot sneak
policy file.
Is that how I would do it ignores
as code or something? Yeah. I I I
I have to admit, this was one of
the things that I had to I was
looking at myself in the documentation just before
the show, and I didn't get to what
how this works. I've never done it.
I think
yeah. It's a it's a obviously, a way
of of creating policies for what what
what you're doing on an ongoing basis. So
I I will look up what those mean,
and I will share with you
at some point in the future.
Awesome.
And b mad says they're gonna start selling
t shirts.
I fully endorse this. In fact, similar designs
and I'll add them to the Rawkode store.
And Russell got excited when you said Azure
and assumed all of us there. Maybe in
time, Russell. Snyk is a fast moving open
source project.
New stuff coming all the time.
Yeah. So so the policies can are things
like ignores,
David. I think it's actually more things you
can do than just ignores, but I I
it's one of those features that I've I've
never used it from the CLI. Mhmm.
Yeah. I can imagine doing it there or
I think I'm not sure what's I think
it's still analyzing.
I mean, my computer is doing a lot
on these streams that I've actually it has
been slowing down more and more.
So hopefully it's just because of that and
it won't take too long.
I am putting it through a lot these
days.
And I have left Docker for Mac running
which is always a bad idea, so let
me
me close that.
That virtual machine just seems to draw a
power like mad. Yeah. I know what you
mean.
But I like the the flow of this,
like, being able to Well, that would be
fine.
Get those little reds Yeah.
So we only have one option there for
for remediating
that one because it doesn't have a fix,
I don't think.
So it's it's saying that you're going to
ignore it and give you a reason for
ignoring it.
And if you I think if you click
through these, they'll they'll they'll go through them
one by one and give you what your
what your options are for for what to
do.
Okay. There you So for this one
yeah. So, again, there isn't any upgrades or
or a patch for that.
The patch the patch stuff's kind of interesting.
So for sometimes where because we've got a
big security team,
you know, obviously doing security research,
Where there might where there aren't
sometimes where there aren't upstream fixes
as in an upgrade pathway,
we will actually release a patch
that you can patch in place. So for
some, you'll see for some vulnerabilities,
there'll be a sneak patch available,
which will just patch it whilst
they're waiting for upstream to fix it.
Oh, yeah. So
don't think they're able fix No.
But that that would give you the, you
know, the automated
way of fixing it if you didn't just
wanna edit the file yourself.
The other interesting thing about the the CLI
is there's a couple of different ways that
you can output the data.
So
there's a an interchange format called Serif that's
very common in security,
but it will also output in JSON.
So what that means is that then you
can do all sorts of of funky stuff
with with JQ
for filtering.
So, you know, I I was playing around
the other day with saying you know, we
talked earlier about saying,
perhaps I only care about vulnerabilities that have
a network
attack path.
So
if
we do do you wanna just do a
scan quickly in JSON, and I'll show you
what the output looks like.
I
think it's just minus minus JSON, is it?
I don't know. I just I was just
guessing.
Let's try. Yes. It's just minus minus JSON.
Yeah. There we go. So if we if
you scroll up a bit there, what what
so, obviously, there's a ton of different information
there,
but the one I was interested in was
the CVSS
score.
Why is that oh, so can you see
that string on there? CVSS v three,
the the up up about four
yeah. See there.
So all of those things respond
correspond
to that.
It's a programmatic way of of representing
that CVSS scoring that we looked at earlier.
So there, see the AVN?
That means that there is a net that's
network exploitable.
So you can filter on these things. You
can build a really complex
if you like that sort of thing, you
know, I'm sure most of us
familiar with familiar with j q? Oh, yeah.
Yeah. David? Yeah.
So and the
the interesting
complexity of building complex g q
filter strings. But yeah. So you could build
you could build you know, if you were
in a CI pipeline and you wanted to
do Snyk test,
but you wanted to ignore certain kinds of
vulnerabilities,
you can set Snyk you can set what
the
the failure is gonna be for a start.
So you could say, like, you know, I
don't want to fail.
I don't wanna return
non zero
on everything.
And then you can make a j q
query that says filter for, you know, things
that only have a
a network. I had a one I was
playing with the other day that
did
kinda do the job. I have to dig
it out.
Oh, so it's not top level. It's
Yeah. You have to do
where was that? I put it in a
blog. Wait one second. Dot filter dot ignore.
Oh, wait. That's not gonna be right. Oh,
there we go.
Filtered with ignore or ignored? I don't remember
now. And then that one Yeah.
I I had had it's vulnerability to see
is the the top level thing.
I've got nowhere to paste anything here, am
I?
I'll tell you what. I don't have to
run the test every time. Why don't we
write it to you? Know you you know
where I'm going with this though is that
there is there is you could build pretty
complex filters
using the JSON output.
Yeah.
Let's see.
So
no. Need to learn how to spell vulnerabilities.
Vulnerabilities.
Yeah. We yeah. Open open close square brackets.
Okay. So mines are ignored, which means I
think they live under filtered. So let's try
that.
Yeah. And then there was a ignored
key.
I shouldn't have opened this can of worm,
should I?
Live j q is not
You don't have to be here all day.
Oh, that that breaks my heart.
Cannot index an array with a string.
That's
a thing.
JQ is always one of those things that
It's like a whole new programming language, isn't
it? Like Yeah. I have to do tons
of googling every time I get it out.
But
Well, I'm sure it's something like piping it
to contains and then looking for AV Yeah.
You do. You do. So yeah. If I
had a if I had somewhere
copy pasting my test one to you, I
would do it. But Okay. So you can
do a select.
You can do a select. So you pipe
that pipe that to select, and then you
select on the on the thing you wanted,
the the element,
and then you
you can filter.
Yeah.
I guess people just have to learn
about that CVSS.
It's just a way of basically a way
of building complex stuff on the CLI. Nice.
You know, if you if you had a
need to do that for any reason, integration,
whatever.
Alright. I like it.
Anything else you wanna show before I flick
those back over to to chatty mode?
Yeah. So it would be nice to show
you this other really cool free thing that
we're that we're doing called adviser.
And so
if you go to snake.i0/adviser,
I think it yeah. Slash adviser.
So this is this is something else we
built that because, you know, we've got all
this data, you know, data on security vulnerabilities,
data on open source projects. So,
there's been a lot of talk recently, and
I and we we talked about it right
at the start, right, about supply chain
security. How do I pick
an open source project? You know? And in
the like I said, in the Python world,
things used to be fairly simple. Right? If
I wanted to do something with HTTP,
I used requests.
That's it. But in newer ecosystems, you can
often have lots of choice about a particular
package.
So how do you choose which package to
use? And it's not just, like, about
what vulnerabilities are in it because as we
all know when we work in open source,
you know, there are other metrics that are
kind of important to open source
things. Right? Like, how how many
different contributions are there? Is it maintained?
You know? Is there a community around it?
Mhmm. So we built this adviser tool to
combine all these data sources. So if you
have a look at the if you go
to PyPy, it's probably easiest, and we can
actually look at something like requests,
you know, which is a a super well
maintained
thing. If you do a search there for
requests,
it's clearly there's some weird type of squatting
things going on here in
in PyPy
with these these things that I don't know
what they are. But if we look at
the main request package, you'll see kinda how
adviser works.
What we get here then is this overall
health score for a particular package, which includes
how popular it is, how well maintained it
is.
Security is obviously one part of it as
well, like, how how
secure is it? But it's this whole kind
of package,
you know, thing for how do I choose
which package to use.
And I think it's super cool.
We're adding more ecosystems to this, you know,
in the next few months. It's kind of
in beta at the minute, But it's a
way for people to be able to, like,
you know,
have a view onto which package should I
use for my project.
And so at the minute, it mainly supports
node and PyPI.
But like I say, we're
NPM and and PyPI, but we're adding ecosystems
to it.
And,
yeah, I'm gonna hopefully do some conference talks
about it as well because I really like
it.
Yeah. Very handy tool. I'm gonna have to
look up lodash now though.
Yeah. So I don't know what that lodash.js
1 is. It's quite sneaky, isn't it? Like,
lodash.js
will send their name and then they've added
on the dash security,
like annotation on the tag version. I mean,
I don't know whether it is typos quote
or whether it's a genuine package that someone's
uploaded. But, you know, we're clearly not scoring
it very highly for some reason or other.
Seems oh, that was suspicious
to me. But there you go. I mean,
may not be suspicious. It may be that's
a one dude who's contributing to it. In
which case, you probably still shouldn't use it
either. Right? Because that dude gets hit by
a bus and then you're in trouble.
Okay. Let's try a Docker one too. Since
we got a comment saying Docker is available
also from b mad. We'll take a quick
look.
Yeah. Docker's in I haven't actually looked too
much into how the what the Docker support
is like in there at the minute.
Yeah. So it's a bit more limited, the
the amount of information on on Docker images.
I know this has been actively
actively developed.
Docker's really new. It's worth saying as well
that you get Docker you get all sorts
of Docker goodness built into Docker as well
these days.
The Docker Hub built in scanning, if you
if you actually have, like, a proper Docker
Hub account, you get free Snyk scanning built
in. And the Docker CLIs
all have Snyk scanning built in for free,
I think,
for for all platforms now. So you can
do Docker scan, and it's exactly the same
as Snyk scan. So you don't even need
to move outside of the docker CLI.
Very cool. Very, very handy tool. I agree
that that's available for everyone. So Snyk.i0/adviser.
Never pick your next package without it. I
think that's my takeaway there.
Yeah.
Yeah. Pick your open source packages like you'd
pick a hotel.
It did offer me an alternative when we
were on the PIPE one for request. It
did actually say like here's alternative packages like
this. That was quite cool. We did. Yeah.
Yeah. I offered another http package.
Oh, a I Yeah. Where you should be.
There we go.
Also leaning in there.
Awesome.
Well, that was a very complete
tour of Snyk.
There there's a lot. Right?
Yeah. Yeah. There's there's more as well. I
mean,
like, there's all sorts of bits that, you
know you know what it's like being DevRel.
You know, you sort of use bits of
the thing and you don't use other bits
of the thing, you know. And often the
people in the real world who are using
these things in anger get to
go in different directions from the direction that
we go in. Yeah. Definitely.
I
was gonna try and summarize everything we've seen,
but I think maybe we're all angry. So
we added a repository on Snyk.io and we
got a whole bunch of vulnerability
information
from the code and from our Docker containers
that were linked
and the Docker files.
We then brought that kind of UI experience
into developer land looking at the Versus code
integration, the really cool,
you know, squiggles in front of my code
front and center as I'm writing that was
a really nice application. Yeah.
I've seen
what bad practices I'm doing. Like, I'm not
sanitizing HTTP inputs and such. That was really
really nice.
We then brought it to the command line
using Snyk test. We also seen the infrastructure
as code for Kubernetes.
I love that that's available for Terraform too.
I'm definitely gonna have to check that out.
And then towards the end, we brought in
the Snyk Advisor and we were looking at
how we can actually understand the health of
the open source libraries that we're consuming as
well.
An awful lot for people to go and
kick their tires on, play with, and enjoy.
Yep. Sign up for a free account. Most
of this, I think almost everything that we've
looked at is all available for free anyway.
So have at it.
Awesome. Well, thank you very much for your
time today, Matt. It's been an absolute pleasure
going through all this work. Thanks for having
me. I enjoyed it. It's been great.
And I hopefully will see you at an
event or conference soon. Yeah. And we can
see you in person. But have a have
a wonderful day and thank you again for
joining me. Thanks all.